my mother did not come
and with no consideration for my prime
which was invested in her not denying
this story that she was supposed to have
asked me to let her know the results of
some search asked from choise to save
these words to me there is no answer
words I have so often since then heard
the doorman in Grand Hotel's or foot men
and bawdy houses bring back to some poor
girl who exclaims in surprise what he
said nothing why that's impossible did
you really give him my note all right
I'll go on waiting and said just as she
invariably assures him she does not need
the extra gas jet that the doorman wants
to light for her and remains there
hearing nothing further but the few
remarks about the weather exchanged by
the doorman and a lackey whom he sends
off suddenly when he notices the time to
put a customer's drink on ice having
declined françoise's offer to make me
some tea or to stay with me I let her
return to the servants Hall I went to
bed and closed my eyes trying not to
hear the voices of my family who were
having their coffee in the garden but
after a few moments I became aware that
by writing that note to my mom by
approaching at the risk of angering her
so close to her that I thought I could
touch the moment when I would see her
again I had shut off from myself the
possibility of falling asleep without
seeing her again and the beating of my
heart grew more painful each minute
because I was increasing my agitation by
telling myself to be calm to accept my
misfortune suddenly my anxiety subsided
a happiness invaded me as when a
powerful medicine begins to take effect
and our pain vanishes I had just formed
the resolution not to continue trying to
fall asleep without seeing mama again to
kiss her at all costs even though it was
with the certainty of being on bad terms
with her for a long time after when she
came up to bed the column that came with
the end of my distress filled me with an
extraordinary joy quite as much as did
my expectation my thirst for and my fear
for danger I opened the window
noiselessly and sat down on the foot of
my bed I hardly moved so that I would
not be heard from below outdoors two
things seemed frozen inside
detention so as not to disturb the
moonlight which duplicating and
distancing each thing by extending its
shadow before it denser and more
concrete than itself headed once thin
and enlarged the landscape like a map
that he unfolded and was now opened out
what needed to move a few leaves of the
chestnut tree moved but they're meant
minut quivering complete executed even
in its slight and slightest nuances and
ultimate refinements did not spill over
onto the rest did not merge with it
remains circumscribed exposed against
this silence which absorb nothing of
them the most distant noises those that
must have come from gardens that lay at
the other end of town could be perceived
detailed with such finish that they seem
to oh this effect of remoteness only to
their pianissimo like those muted motifs
so well executed by the orchestra of the
conservatory that although you do not
lose a single note nonetheless think you
were hearing them far away from the
concert hall and all the old subscribers
my grandmother's sisters too wen Suan
had given them his seats strain their
ears as if they were listening to the
distant advances of an army on the march
that did not yet turned the corner on
the Rue de tivities I knew that the
situation I was now placing myself in
was the one that could provoke the
gravest consequences of all for me
coming from my parents much graver in
truth than a stranger could have
supposed the sort he would have believed
could be produced only by truly shameful
misdeeds but in my upbringing the order
of misdeeds was not the same as an that
of other children and I had become
accustomed to placing before all the
rest before there were probably no
others from which I needed to be more
carefully protected those whose common
characteristic I now understood was that
you lapse into them by yielding to a
nervous impulse but at the time no one
uttered these words no one revealed this
cause which might have made me believe I
was excusable for succumbing to them or
even perhaps incapable of resisting them
but I recognized them clearly from the
egg
wish that preceded them as well as well
as from the rigor of the punishment that
followed them and I knew that the one I
have just committed was in the same
family as others for which I had been
severely punished though infinitely
braver when I went and placed myself and
my mother's path at the moment she was
going up to bed and when she saw that I
had stayed up to say goodnight to her
again in the hallway they would not let
me continue to live at home they would
send me away to school the next day that
much was certain well even if i had had
to throw myself out of the window five
minutes later i still prefer this what i
wanted now was mama to say goodnight to
her i had gone too far along the road
that led to the fulfillment of that
desire to be able to turn back now I
heard my parents footsteps as they saw
Swan out and when the belle of the gate
let me know he had gone I went to the
window my mom was asking my father if he
had thought the lobster was good and if
Monsieur Swan had had more coffee and
pistachio minus I found it quite
extraordinary said my mother I think
next time we'll have to try another
flavor I can't tell you how I have
changed i find swans of my great aunt he
has aged so my great aunt was so used to
seeing Swan always is the same
adolescent that she was surprised to
find him suddenly not as young as the
age she continued to attribute to him
when my family was also beginning to
feel that in him this aging was abnormal
excessive shameful and more deserved by
the unmarried by all those for whom it
seems that the great day that has that
has no tomorrow is no longer than for
others because for them it is empty and
the moments in it add up from morning on
without them being divided among
children I think he's had no end of
worries with that wretched wife of his
who is living with a certain Monsieur de
chartres loose as olive come clean knows
it's the talk of the town my mother
pointed out that in spite of this he had
been looking much less sad for some time
now he also doesn't make that gesture of
his as often so like his father of
wiping his eyes and running his hand
across his forehead I think myself that
in his heart of hearts he no longer
loves
woman why naturally he doesn't love her
anymore answered my grandfather I
received a letter from him about it a
long time ago by now a letter from which
i hastened not to comply and which
leaves no doubt about his feelings at
least his feelings of love for his wife
well now you see you didn't thank him
for the asti added my grandfather
turning to his two sisters in law what
we didn't thank you I think just between
you and me that I put it quite
delicately answered my head flora yes
you managed it very well quite admirable
said my aunt Celine but you were very
good too yes I was really proud of my
remark about the kinds of a kind
neighbors what is that what you call
thanking him exclaimed my grandfather I
certainly heard that but the devil take
me if I thought it was directed at Swan
you can be sure he never noticed but see
here Swan isn't stupid I'm sure he
appreciated it after all I couldn't tell
him how many bottles uh-uh I couldn't
tell him how many bottles there were in
what the wine costs my father and mother
were left alone there and sat down for a
moment then my father said well should
we go up to bed if you like my dear even
though I'm not the least bit sleepy but
it couldn't be that perfectly harmless
coffee ice that's keeping me so wide
awake but I can see a light go on in the
servants Hall and since poor Francois
has waited up for me I'll go and ask her
to unhook my bodice while you're getting
undressed and my mother opened the
lattice store and led from the vestibule
to the staircase soon I heard her coming
up the stairs to close her window I went
without a sound into the hallway my
heart was beating so hard I had trouble
walking but at least I was no longer it
was no longer pounding from anxiety but
from terror and joy I saw the light cast
in that stairwell by Mama's candle then
I saw mama herself I threw myself
forward in the first sent second she
looked at me with astonishment not
understanding what could have happened
then an expression of anger came over
her face she did not say a single word
to me and indeed for much less than this
they would go several days without
speaking to me if my mind said one word
to me it would have been an admission
that they
talk to me again and in any case it
would have perhaps seemed to me even
more terrible as a sign that given the
gravity of the punishment that was going
to be prepared for me silence and
estrangement would have been childish a
word would have been like the calm with
which you answer a servant when you have
just decided to dismiss him the kiss you
give a sum you were sending off to
enlist whereas you would have refused if
you were if you were simply going to be
annoyed with him for a few days but she
heard my father coming up from the
dressing room where he had gone to
undress and to avoid the scene he would
make over me she said to me in a voice
choked with anger run run so is so at
least her father won't see you waiting
like this as if you were out of your
mind but I repeated to her come say
goodnight to me terrified as I saw the
gleam from my father's candle already
rising up the wall but also using his
approach as a means of blackmail and
hoping that Mama to avoid my father's
finding me they're still if she
continued to refuse would say go back to
your room I'll come it was too late my
father was there in front of us
involuntarily there no one heard i
murmured these words undone for it was
not so my father was constantly refusing
me permission for things that have been
authorized and the more generous
covenants grant granted by my mother and
grandmother because he did not bother
about principles and for him there was
no rule of law for a completely
contingent reason or even for no reason
at all he would at the last minute deny
me a certain walk that was so customary
so consecrated that did to bribe me of
it was a violation or as he had done
once again this evening long before the
ritual hour he would say to me go up now
up to bed no arguments but also because
he had no principles in my grandmother
since he was not strictly speaking
intransigent he looked for me for a
moment with an expression of surprise
and annoyance then as soon as mama had
explained to him with a few embarrassed
words what had happened he said to her
go along with him then you were just
saying you didn't feel very sleepy
staying his room for a little while I
don't hate anything but my dear answered
my mother timid
whether i'm sleepy or not doesn't change
anything we can't let the child get into
the habit but it isn't a question of
habits that my father shrugging his
shoulders you can see the boy is upset
he seems very sad look we're not
executioner's you'll end by making him
ill and that won't do us much good there
are two beds in his room go tell
françoise's to prepare the big one for
you and sleep there with him tonight now
then good night I'm not as high strung
as the two of you I'm going to bed Oh No
pouvez pas one Fc a vampire oh new day
gasps a parsec ela play decency very
joyous day so saucy pheromone l88 on
court Avenue gone no sahab de nuit
blanche pseudo kashmir the land vo De
Niro's King Louie or tortoise etete
typical avid in effigy avec leur jest
dobrze harm don't like a very bonito
católica mevennen a masseuse juan de
santis aha que la casa de partir du côté
de Zack yah bian de sonido solo na mere
idle escalade usually montilla of
flavors apogee exist proved to be not on
my OC beyond a shows on TTT treat koja
quiet of order a true edenville so
deadly donnelly nice on sat a pen and
each one Val cusion ami più clave para
la demande coalescence en mousse onto
the new GV silicon pan-european Antonio
see compare assessee the poverty romano
valve avec la pitié a possibility to
tell sir novanet culture may pour moi me
Dupree put it on Giroux commence at
Clarion pairs of our CEO craig laura the
song lil cuz you juste la vostra come
too near the vampire a connect latere
could consume over to be so
that memo on reality nadja miss sa he
says son mom parts cada vez su camión de
volta otro tomorrow kajal isn't on de
nouveaux come see close to curve on coo
coo sybian libera la vie fondo de jour
Conley querida at nikki's / meta Sony
Donna she knows Suswam naman passes at
minado mahjong o mundo joven need to
come entering food tell coach a matinee
I told leshia the ki te llamas on my
phone lack of deep recession is jame up
to neuter camry composed in biloxi on my
mother you also manifest a pass across
the country to mon pere Imani gar gar de
su kare toh shows their betrayal a
demerit a killer character is a a ketone
a oscar general more and received a
Pluto de convenance for treat hood and
plump remedied a potato Mancuso kuja
plays a severity containment wag mo gue
shee maritima soon casal de manera
mahamaya casa nature pretty fair amount
of certain parkland de la mian cuneta
dollar navico bad omen padova nice kissy
community maneuver to lay soir Tsukema
mayor Mohammad Sahib young may L mamiya
soprano Parkinson tearin' me apart
needless Oh Franz el bulli makan holla
domine Evangeline um accessibility
nervous a 40 fema volante from impaired
Don affection for Maya T do not result
John SI possa Larry to secure our
foreign fois will veneto compound kuzava
douche agarra la vida llamame valent la
consola mom arrested melanoma saw a
comprar new company gotta do come home
or caesar see different tasuku chavez
you luda despair a conference was comp
anoche so passive quelque chose the
extraordinary on why ominous esprit de
moi to mutiny lamb now in malaysia
samahan deal with Amanda me madam k
don't miss European see my Mondrian
Louie depandi me a new see partly mem
françoise's Illidan herve prepare
immediately only in montival coucher an
SI por la première fois mattress tesna
tip you consider a common foot penis ab
mechanimal and volunteer convent of a
cadet officiel more common a tania da
genetic power response al joven loose to
lachemann de Navarre plumber ladies
[ __ ] alam a human arm to pull the
place on a shame genetic panel blue
media common fear vis a vie de france
was the servitor day shows a man he
winner a break mama de souza demoted
Amish on em avait fait des des news male
porn kozodav a dormir Nelly valid in ET
de haan person a midi Phaeton to thank
uu are inserted the puberty to shadow
demon sebastien de la giorgio her jean
de leche para el meson de cama Marvin
Demoff Aaron premiere concession kiddo
very otra de las cosas de enfermera
dication dosa are devon lee de alcalá
vacanze con su forma a cupola premiere
fois l see crushers salve wave a coup in
Mozambique OC giovanni da important
victoire set a contra el rosario cecum
or a poor fella melody d shegaon
large-eyed in town josé volante a fair
flesh years Arizona equal tsutsui a
common say you nay kamasan a rest area
community stood at see Chavez's amet no
Jory teamo no notion of
new couche pas ici mejor con el cielo
Sasha's pratik realist commandery will
be key tampa bay on el nature of the
moon ed a list tomorrow man is your
cervical met normality feel LM mmm you
melissa dimarco atilla precio kalmo i
doona Padawan je m'appelle Sara LeBeau
visage drama mayor brian carter jonas
soo swallow when mutiny seduce a monomer
is cherchez La Femme alarm me just among
us on play castle on your iPad you at
sekolah rotating one twist for my
preceptor serve you well canary papua
new moon or false Emerson Lake
rejuvenating ma and pa saket the casa
das anom and premier read ad fara pahat
and Pommier overblown said ponse Rajab
la maison bleue ownership in my mouth
jamendo solicitor nestle sa alia who can
Intuit only smart ma attitude and COO
Ghani par de mieux que si a devotee una
vida blue a commensal TQ Germany Tia
pursue and madiha me on voila mon petit
jean name of 87 give a laundress am
among Otzi pataskala por poco solar
continue way on Prisca tuna paso me Nita
mamanam you know estampa news a nerve a
frozen calcio shows panel and a live
version on avait pas la escritura or him
10 plus year sir joseph italy a dejar
leave to critical merited on a boat
effect also be on to new survey pas de
su dinero en avoir a play tomorrow gto
can Claire on Shanti a mama a la sección
package leave da una puta divini
acapella poppy Achilles envelope a good
high court a large Mickey soup Ramirez
bay port on summer in wale eclipse a
deja la water cooler
Jordan olivares wat de l'an dernier set
a llamar o dr Francois Lucien p la
Petite vedet le métro so no megami
yasuda pre aveda bourgeoisie lip residue
mercy on vol de su Indiana car co
usually lecture furtillo sea mas ancho
de bombon la pâtisserie a new principal
egg souffle de Chagny use sur les prix
member not far enough humans Prudential
hers in 1 v.v fuel consumption curve
llegando y levanta la même imperiling on
prescott ready to fall on up a
pronounced lee live ruling bodoni elated
attorney and memory live account she'll
deliver hair porque si no es casado new
passive arm on cod cod o Satan as your
boy Bruno le tiran crisis we found
glumetza avid a ver tema mayor luna
policy so that again SI ayer el cetera
robert riebs early cattle himansh on
petrol georgia so on my feet digital
imamo juniper a moody CD Adonia certain
form quelque chose de mal III